So, we are back with the question answer session and so the first question is what is the difference
between data type integer and integer 64. So, see the when we were doing the coding there
were integer 64 then integer 32 you can even use integer 16, 16. So, actually if I go in
depth this involves the concept of bits and bytes. So, how many bytes would be in the computer
memory would be used for representing a specific numbers converting it to its binary value.
So, not going into its depth. So, if you just specify it like in the data type d type
of the array if you just write i and t it would somewhat take the default one that is
I guess 64 if I am not wrong and changing the 64 to 32 or 16 that would have less number
of bits representing a number. So, when we are talking about very large numbers high taking
this integer 64 is better because more number of bits are reserved to represent a number
in the computer memory. So, next question please why the double squared bracket for 2D arrays
actually yeah and in the example that is those are curly braces given, but actually their
brackets would be there that is the convention of writing 2D arrays in python. So, actually
not for any specific purpose we are giving that. So, for 2D arrays you are supposed to
write it like that so that python understands it if like some days before some new version
of python comes that makes use of anything else suppose angular bracket brackets instead
of square brackets then we would have to give angular brackets. So, those are that is convention
of using the square brackets. So, next question please can we form a 2D array
from a 1D array a defined in MPIN yeah this is a very good question; obviously we can
create a 2D array. So, when we were teaching learning the reshape function so when we have
this 1D array of 8 elements 1D array of 8 elements suppose 0 through 7 so we have 8
elements and when we were reshaping it dot reshape 2 comma 3 so 2 rows and 3 columns.
So, now that is a 2D array or a matrix of 2 rows and 3 columns. So, obviously what we
are doing from 1D array we can converting it to a 2D array not just 2D array we can
convert it to 3D array also. So, when we are talking about 8 elements if you reshape it
to 2 comma 2 comma 2; that means, 2 rows and 2 columns and of 2 different 2D matrices.
So, you might be having a trouble understanding this, but if you play around if you use that
reshape function if you try to write code on your own for defining 3D arrays you would
be clear how and even I would encourage you to even go higher dimension like try 4 dimension
or 5 dimension and check how things appear try to print them ok.
Next question please can I define the sepal length and width manually rather than taking
it from ish df taken from ish data url how to do that ok. So, obviously you can manually
do everything it is not at all necessary for you to get the data through url what you can
do when we open the url in our browser tab what you can do you can save it and possibly
it would be saved in a dot CSV file that is comma separated value and you can using pandas
you can read the that file that you have downloaded through by giving it specific location in
that pd dot read CSV function and you would be able to get the data on your own and instead
of sepal length width these are these are conventionally the values of sepal length
and width. So, we go through that in the description of the data. So, we are getting this instead
of this you can give your wishing other names whatever you wish, but the aim is to correct
the correct it correctly predicting like correctly doing the classification task. So, today like
very naively I told you drawing lines in between those different scatter plot points and next
week onwards you would be actually learning machine learning models which like magnificently
do this works for us of classification and another thing regression you would learn.
So, next question please done. Thank you.